while you're on the journey you have to
disconnect from the end goal I think
every time I say I'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble I never want to be always right
because then I can't grow I can't learn
I always want to outdo everybody else
around me I'm a very competitive person
I'm just quiet about it you know I use
positive inspiration as opposed to like
a bit like oh ah Stowe's I keep a
constant notepad and just ideas
play-by-play I'm a naturally poised
individual you have to do something that
nobody else is done or else there's no
point that's how I see it if that
product that you have is potent enough
you will be the next big thing
something's gonna happen it's only he's
a comedian rapper singer songwriter
record producer and actor his work has
earned him a Grammy Award three Juno
Awards and six BDT Awards he has the
most number one singles on the Billboard
Hot Rap Songs chart he's Dre and here
are his top ten rules for success I
don't care about number like I don't
want number one spots it's just like you
know four or five weeks ago every there
was another guy that was not in the
number one spot according to the entire
world and then next week two weeks from
now when somebody else does it that all
these discussions about like I said
number ones and classics and I don't
want it I don't care I just want to make
good music and I just want you to enjoy
it and as long as we have that
relationship for the duration of this
career I'm good like I don't need it
like I don't you know I'm a and maybe
that's why people say I'm there because
I really I disconnect from it you know
my uncle always told me something early
in my life which stuck with me which is
that while you're on the journey you
have to disconnect from the end goal you
know because if you're just focused on
some end goal than your you might get
there but it'll be hard to progress past
that because you're so focused on that
one destination that it's like you know
you you maybe forget everything in
between and maybe you could have done
more in between just be he always told
me like just be here right now live
right now and do the best you can right
now don't worry about what that end goal
is it's great to have goals it's great
to have dreams but it's just like you
get too attached to it
it could be a self-destructive thing so
I mean I just kind of try and progress
as much as I can like right now I think
every time I say I'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble that's probably one of the
biggest motivations behind a lot of my
raps is the amount of people that want
me to fall or whatever I think that that
should be the motivation for most
rappers you know the further you climb
towards the top the more the more hands
you have on your pant leg dragging you
to the bottom they just start tugging at
you but you know I wear really strong
pants I never want to be always right
because then I can't grow I can't learn
so I have no desire to be always right I
need mistakes you know and luckily
enough and not going on this wooden
piano here
that like you know my mistakes are never
crucial enough for me to be like man you
know they're always great learning
experiences I always want to outdo
myself I always want to outdo everybody
else around me I'm a very competitive
person I'm just quiet about it I'm not
really out there like talking about who
I wanted out do I'd rather just go and
outdo it you know what I'm saying as
opposed to just sitting back and being
like oh you know I don't need to tell
you who I'm better than or who I'm
trying to be better than I just want to
put my music out and then you tell me
who's who's better than then you know
I'm saying that's a beat i'li I leave it
I leave it up to the people you know and
as far as like how do i how do I get
better I push myself really hard I mean
I have great opinions in the studio you
know like me myself hush we all sit in
the studio and I'm sorry me myself hush
that makes no sense me forty and hushed
um I need that drink whenever you guys
are ready so yeah you know we all sit in
the studio and I don't I don't sacrifice
like oh I try not to sacrifice any bar
you know I mean I'll I'll sit there on
on the last two lines of a verse for
three four days if I need to you know
just to figure out how to end it
you know I want it to be cohesive I
always want this beginning a verse to be
strong I always want the end to be
strong and I really really really spend
a lot
time on bars man you know um luckily for
me melodies come extremely easy you know
knock on wood like but they do i mean
III that is something that naturally
like I just get in there and it starts
flowing and by you know forty minutes in
an hour and I have pretty much the
direction I'm going in but when it comes
to raps I spend a lot of time on him and
I'm not gonna sit here and be like oh
you know that's all off the top baby you
know I'm saying right now I spend a lot
of time when you're in the lab going and
crapped in the music is this somebody
that you think about from your past that
you're like you know what every sounds
such as such gave me a wedgie well
favorite sound that girl like fronted on
me I do this for that you know I do this
for that no it's more um it's more the
influential people that I know I don't
really think about me but I did negative
things to me I think about the
individuals like uh like Wayne like Ross
like yeh like the guys that I know you
know if I take tonight off I know that
one of them is probably in the studio
crafting something magical you know so I
should probably stay a little longer I
should probably not go to the club I
should just you know work because I know
that there's somebody else working if I
decide to go play you know I'm saying so
I just use like individuals you know and
especially like probably one of the most
people like in that regard obviously its
main but you know as well Jay is one of
those guys - that's one that like you
can guarantee if he's going in there
rapping missing something something
great so I just use people you know I
use positive inspiration as opposed to
like I've seen it like all men Acosta's
all good I mean I'm in a great positive
headspace right now I don't want to give
anybody no problem
I don't want no problems I just want
people like
so my think is like usually when I'm in
my phone you know it's because you said
something you said something if someone
said something that's prompted me to be
like oh I got to write that down doesn't
have to rhyme you know right away it
doesn't have to be you know a thought
you know it doesn't have to be a bar it
just can be like something you said like
even like I think the last thing I wrote
down was like someone last night was I'm
at feel like I've become a recluse and I
was like then recluse that's such a
great word I love that word that's right
now write down like use the word recluse
you know right so if your Rekluse in the
rapids because someone said someone said
it right so just like those type of
things I mean I keep a constant notepad
of just ideas play-by-play if you read
through that notepad you can really see
where my mind is at where my life is at
but no one is allowed to read through
that okay I made a commitment very early
on to just be myself you know and what
really bothers me the most is the fact
that you know sometimes I feel like I
don't get enough credit or I'm not
making a big enough impact because I'm
not enough of a loose cannon you know in
situations like this where we're doing a
one-on-one interview or you know that
people just want me to go off more and
lose my composure and then that way you
know I guess maybe I would be like make
more headlines or be more iconic but
that's not me you know I'm a I'm a
naturally poised individual I don't want
to just come out you know making
mistakes and having to be like a hobby
that's the thing right like you said you
know a lot of artists just have my space
and just have you know a couple songs
and don't have it what website don't
have marketing don't have anything and
then they get disappointed when they
only sell like 70 records you know and
it's like you got to understand that
this is about marketing like this whole
thing is about marketing it's about your
image it's about your story you got to
be appealing to people and if you're
gonna release a record in Canada you
have to do something that nobody else is
done or else there's no point that's how
I see it so all I want to say is what do
I have to do or any artists in this room
have to do to get notice by you that's a
great question I think I think that for
anybody what you have to understand is
like
there's a there's a way to exist in this
world that's like it we've never had it
before but like I I strongly believe in
the fact that if you have a good product
for the first time ever there's a way to
like get the world to hear your product
and if it's good you will see the
results from it you understand I'm
saying like there's people that you know
artists will drop a mixtape and if that
makes tape picks up you know whether
it's like house of balloons or
partynextdoor like he'll get like I
remember seeing when house of balloons
drop I remember people being like yo I'm
in the Netherlands right now listening
the house of balloons it's like what
like you know we have such a platform to
access the entire world and my biggest
thing to you your question was how do
you like I guess catch the attention
it's just about finding your own moment
you know and and and having them music
be great as cliche as that sounds but
it's just like man you know there's not
a lot of great music to choose from so
when somebody is great the world will
let you know trust me it doesn't take me
it doesn't take this guy the world will
let you know all you have to do is put
it out there and there are people who
scour the internet every day looking for
the next big thing and I promise you if
that product that you have is potent
enough you will be the next big thing
and I feel like that's it you know
gentlemen the movie is testing through
the roof we're gonna have ourselves a
hit right I just want to say it's all
thanks to this guy man I love working
with you right straight up you know when
we started this movie you and I were
co-stars now you're my brother all we
need now is a title ok
um well I mean best to keep it simple no
it's like Drake and Blake wasn't yeah in
it
we could call yeah maybe but I also like
Blake and drink Blake
yeah do we long blade enjoy though or do
we like genuinely love Drake and Blake
like right when you hear it why don't we
just take the beginning of my name and
the end of your name and just Blake BAM
Blake
well done let us bear VanDerveer better
the pilot is compared to it
yeah yeah it just gets like it's like
hard to say you know it's like black
black and Drake what's like Drake and
Blake Drake and play guys guys guys go
ahead okay we have a week to make this
decision I mean I'm sure something will
happen to make Blake change his mind
oh something's gonna happen something's
gonna happen it's all hey cutie hey
someone sent you at work a gram okay
well let's get to twerking and what's up
Oh God
oh wait wait I thought fish was a car
commercial ski the tub
Slate's up please and action there you
go it's a great day everyone's happy and
look back look at the horizon look at
your career look what you've become who
cut his hair for this that's what
happened all right once the anesthesia
kicks in we will be removing the
patient's appendix but first there's
doughnuts in the kitchen guys what oh
god you're the surgeon oh I'm not the
surgeon he is
Breezie the Internet has killed you for
doing too much flapping how do you
respond to your critics I would like to
say as Blake Griffin that I love floppy
you know I mean there's so much demanded
of me that you know a lot of the time
it's just better for me to fall down and
take a little rest hey what's up
everybody I'm Drake and this message
goes out to all of my fans you I really
don't have much integrity they try to
get me to do the NBA Cares commercials
and I always kindly decline you decline
the NBA Cares
I'm not really I'm just not into
children all right all right all right
let me lay it down this is the new son
of Drake right here skee bop shoo bop
bop bop bah I am drinking I like you
girl I think a lot of people are
extremely confused about my face I kind
of look like a black guy that jumped
into a pit of Cheetos and just laid
there for for like 10 days and then
popped up
I tell people I'm half-black but really
I don't know
do you know what team has the most white
players cuz that's probably where I want
to go I'm not sure you're gonna have a
career after this and let's print that I
like it a lot I think that's gonna be
great I think it's really gonna up my
street cred so what do you think Donald
Sterling's message was that not all
people are equal and I agree with it I'm
actually glad this is being filmed
anyway I'm Blake Griffin part of the
dominant white race and I would just
like to let thank you guys so much for
watching we made this video because
right online ask the student if you have
any famous entrepreneurs of you want us
to profile next please leave it below
I'd also love to know which of Drake's
rules meant the most to you have the
biggest impact leaving the comments
below I will join the discussion thank
you so much for watching and continue to
believe and we'll see you soon